kanye could have damn near anybody yeah
so why do you think he picked kim
as a guy because i have a theory okay
that sometimes hoes get wiped wifed up
faster than prudes you did say you have
said this
before um why why would he have chosen
her i think i think because they're
probably as crazy as each other to be
honest i think they're as crazy as each
other um
and let's be honest she like she was the
first this whole kind of kim was the
poster girl for
she set the curve the curvaceous beauty
standard
of like the current like modern era do
you know what i mean because before her
it was all about being slim like yeah
being skinny like the model s one that
was the only beauty standard now every
girl wants bob wants a bum wants boobs
and that's because of her so like i'm
not saying he chose her to be a trophy
wife but like he was like yeah i got
that like the it girl do you know what i
mean yeah i think that was the first
attraction and then you know she can
have this crazy